so kanye flew home last night
and he came back this morning i want to
show you guys what he got me
[Music]
gorgeous
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
kanye west made his debut on hulu's the
kardashians with a grand gesture for kim
i know his heart the 44 year old rapper
appeared on the latest episode of the
famous family's new reality show flying
to la then nyc in coach to deliver a
special gift to his estranged wife i
just traveled to get something for ken
you went all the way to la to get
something for kim
you were something else what did you get
well that's what she wants to try at the
time the 41 year old skims founder was
in the big apple to host saturday night
live and had recently learned that ray
jay's manager claimed to have unreleased
footage from her old sex tape with the
one wish singer the last thing that i
want as a mom is from my past to be
brought up
20 years later this is some real
embarrassing
and i need to deal with it and i will
deal with it well turns out yay dealt
with it
he got me all of the sex tape
oh my god and he flew home he got
a computer was on the hard drive
and he met up with ray j at the airport
and got it all back
oh my god that's amazing
yep
kanye brought back the whole computer in
a suitcase people you have a real
insight into what the girls are doing
not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes
before you would see little snippets of
something and now i think the episodes
are
you know fuller of content that shows
the whole story i know kanye did this
for me but he also did this for my kids
i want to shield them from as much as i
can and if i had the power to or if
kanye has the power to
like that is just the most important
thing to me and i'm just like so
emotional because of it
and i just
it just means a lot to me the reality
star filed for divorce from the musician
back in february 2021 and all that sex
tape in a suitcase business went down
several months later in october
thank you for kanye and for his
unbelievable way he does things and the
ability to get something done that was
amazing you did well you also knew how
much it meant to her and how hard she's
been trying to do that for years and
years of course kim started dating snl
star pete davidson shortly after her
hosting gig where the kkw beauty founder
puckered up to the 28 year old comedian
in this aladdin parody i like you just
the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
fast forward about six months and a
source tells et the lovebirds are in a
great place in their relationship adding
that kim is so happy and she feels light
and fun when he's around what's your
favorite thing about him um
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing
and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing
what about the goal is finding someone
to do nothing with it's the best because
you can do everything with
distracted but you can't be with anyone
and do nothing plus e.t source says her
family loves him too which echoes what
the famous fam told et earlier this
month i love that he's kind
and really really thoughtful he's the
most thoughtful person
and i love yeah and i love the chemistry
that cam and him have together it's
really sweet i thought you said the
chemistry i it's like okay chemistry
chemistry
[Music]